good morning at 7 56 i'm john lyon we're
following breaking news this morning in
the south valley a murder investigation
from metro police bianca holman live at
the scene with the details bianca
good morning john so in the home just
past this yellow tape on seasons avenue
a man was shot and killed and so we're
told that that man was trying to break
into the house where a woman lived with
her three children and also her current
boyfriend was there so the man that was
trying to break in was an ex-boyfriend
he tried to come in through two
different windows once he got inside
while she was on the phone with 9-1-1
she saw that the woman had a handgun so
he left the house came back and as he
was pointing his gun to her current
boyfriend's head the woman shot the man
and when medical
arrived they pronounced the man dead so
now at this time those details are
preliminary the kids are okay the woman
and her current boyfriend are okay
they're saying it's self-defense but of
course as the investigation continues
we'll keep you updated online and on air
bianca holmen live local now